every business needs more storage not
that storage that's right
cloud storage make that IBM Cloud object
storage designed to save you money with
continuous data availability and the
security you need this is IBM Cloud
object storage integrated with Watson
turning ordinary data into extraordinary
insights for your business so you can
store and analyze millions of images and
videos know what the world is saying
about your brand and real time speed
collaboration and genomic Cancer
Research and build killer apps in the
cloud without limits
IBM Cloud object storage always
available secure AI ready
[Music]